all right next we've got a surprising
new study on wearing your mask the
guardian reports researchers at cardiff
university found that people were rated
more attractive with a mask on
participants were shown photos of both
men and women with no mask
a medical mask
with a cloth mask and then with a book
covering the bottom of their face and by
far the medical masks picked were rated
hottest followed by cloth masks ross
yeah thought well i think this is
fascinating i mean it has really changed
the way i interact with new people
because think about people you've met
just in the past two years you only know
what they look like like this right i i
play a game show like you know a weak
chin or jawline every time i'm about to
see somebody when they take their mask
off i don't know what the rest of your
face looks like so i get to make it up
which is which makes you hotter because
i promise you i'm making you hotter than
you are in my head that's so nice yeah
that's and by the way you are welcome
for that because some of us some of us
need the help honey some of us do you
need no help rossi well thank you so
much very handsome well but do you think
that's fine like have you known someone
for a while and then you finally see
them for the first time without a match
absolutely and it's always a shocker
right absolutely some people look so
different
and you're like oh i was okay great and
some people look kind of exactly the
same my theory on the reason like
this
isn't gonna do it for people is a mask
actually puts a little smile so it's
actually
not a bad shape there's there's a little
bit of a liftage smileage sort of um
you know positive lineage interesting
point of view going on yeah
you know what i found i'm talking like
straight up geometrics i'm impressed all
right next up we got a whole new
category of workout gear anybody trying
to get themselves in shape i know i'm in
the fight we all always
well wall street journal reports you can
now wear your weights with weighted
leggings so weights are sewn into the
pants like you've seen people wear like
yoga pants so they they sew weights into
them to increase the active load on your
muscles and maximize the workout that
you're already doing so imagine if they
put weights on your leggings you're
walking around think how many extra
calories you're burning right
i am
really intrigued i'm almost like how did
this not come about sooner
this is brilliant i know i want to try
them like i wish i had them on right now
and i could just stand up and like rip
my pants off like magic mike you know
well huh i mean what if i
what if i got up
for example
and i unbuttoned my blazer and i just
grabbed my pants like this and ripped
them off
[Music]
and kick and kick
and kick
girl
you got good legs don't objectify me
don't
no you really do have beautiful legs
this was a good idea and then i felt
myself out there now i don't like it
i'm feeling you too rossi really it has
been a long time for you hasn't it
that's right it has
well rossi i'm going to stare at you all
commercial break long don't you hide
those beautiful stems away from us i'll
be right back
[Music]